hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be giving you
the two
magic words that you need to secure
property investment deals
now if you're new to my channel thanks
so much for checking it out don't forget
to subscribe
and turn the notification bell on if
you're back as a regular visitor
smash the like button drop a comment
below as the more comments we get below
means the more people this video will
reach so listen i've been investing in
property now for over a decade
and i remember when i first wanted to
start viewing houses and putting forward
offers it was really scary because i
didn't know these two magic words i'm
going to share with you in a moment and
the thing that put me off viewing houses
was the estate agent saying to me so
would you like to put forward an offer
because if you put forward an offer
let's say you viewed a house for 100
grand
you put forward an offer then what then
they're going to say yes and then you've
got to buy it
and you might not have the money so if
you've not got the money you've not got
your ducks in a row
you can't then ring up an agent because
if you ring up an agent they're going to
get you to book the viewing
then they're going to ask you to put in
an offer and you can't put an offer
because you don't have the money so it
says constant catch
22 of what comes first the chicken or
the egg should you save up loads of
money
and then when you've got the cash then
go and negotiate like a pro and start
putting forward loads of offers
or what how does it work and the truth
is you need to learn these two words and
the two words are
if and would if
would and let me put this into some
context because if is a hypothetical
word so
i'll give you an example you view a
house the house is on for a hundred
thousand pounds
you're interested in the deal so instead
of saying to them i could buy it for 80
000 pounds you're gonna say instead
you're gonna say
if i put forward an offer of around
about eighty thousand pounds
what would they say you know
that that's what you're gonna say so
listen if i put food enough for about 80
000 pounds what what do you think they
would say
and then the estate agent might say oh
you know what it's a little bit low i
think they'd accept more like 85 000.
and then you're going to say okay cool
leave that with me and i'll get back to
you
so now you've viewed the house you've
not put forward your offer but you've
done your
if would offer and you've now got an
idea of how much they'll accept
now this if would i use it for
everything i use this for
putting forward offers i use it for
dealing with builders
i use it for dealing with estate agents
for investors when i'm deal packaging
it would and these two words you've
gotta master these two words and when
and where to use it i'll give you
another example
let's say you are wanting to package a
deal and you want to pass it on to an
investor
now what do you what what do you do
first do you find the investor first or
do you find the deal first
because imagine if you find a deal it's
a really good deal but then you try and
sell it to an investor and you say hey
i've got this deal
and i've just had it wrapped up at 85
000 pounds
do you want it and then the investors
are saying i'm not sure i need to think
about it
but you've put forward this offer with
the estate agent so you you're stuffed
now
because the estate agent is going to be
breathing down your neck that's why you
want to use if wood with the estate
agent but i also use it with the
investor
so before i even view a house let's say
if i'm viewing somehow some hmos in
birmingham
i'll contact some investors and i'll say
to the investors what kind of deals are
you looking for oh i'm looking for some
high returning properties okay would you
be open to
some uh hmos in birmingham yeah i'd be
open you know okay well listen
if here's the input again talking to a
property investor now
listen if i if i could find some really
good high cash flowing properties in
birmingham would you be interested
if would uh yeah i would actually be
really interested okay cool well if you
give me your business card and your
email
i'll keep you posted all right great and
listen
if wood again i use this constantly this
is my biggest secret if would
um okay well well listen if i if i can
find something over the next few days
would you be in a position where you can
pay me a finder's way
if would ah i don't know i mean i'm not
quite ready yet all right cool now you
know where you stand so you're going to
if with the next person
so honestly you need to
learn if and would now i am going to be
running a webinar it's going to be a
free webinar
okay um and i'm going gonna be talking
in much more detail about how to
package and sell deals how to negotiate
so if you're interested in some further
training
and learning the language i'll leave a
link in the description below click on
it
and i've got a few free advanced
webinars with me personally coming up
i i'd love to hear if you have success
trying this strategy
comment in the description box below
what you think and i look forward to
seeing the next video if you want to
learn more about negotiations
how to find property deals and negotiate
you can check out a video that i did up
here it's a really cool video
if you want to hear stories of people
that have won in property as a result of
my training and my webinars
then check out this playlist right here
don't forget to subscribe over here and
again if you want to do the advanced
training with me
check out the description i'll see you
there